Globalization is a phenomenon that connects the world,
uniting nations,
economies and cultures.
Globalization is an economic,
social,
political,
technological and cultural process on a planetary scale
characterized by progressive integration and interaction between countries,
people and institutions.
That is,
it is a phenomenon that facilitates the exchange of ideas and goods.
Provides opportunities for economic growth and development.
s of globalization globalization also promotes global.
This opens doors to new relations between countries and cultures.
In addition,
globalization favors cultural diversity,
exposing us to different cultures,
traditions and ways of life.
Finally,
globalization helps us to understand and accept
our differences by building a more united world.
You were served this information by Follow us and share this publication.
Seat Admission.